4:30 p.m. on a Thursday afternoon in
Johannesburg South Africa it's 2008 and
when a myth of a global financial crisis
the largest one since the dot-com bubble
in the year 2000 rumors are swirling
about the global economy collapsing
about banks going bankrupt about people
losing their jobs I'm a commodity trader
in an investment bank and with only 30
minutes to go until the market closes I
can't wait because phones around me
ringing uncontrollably and computer
screens are flashing non-stop it's a
tense environment and one where
everybody's trying to manage their
profits to keep their jobs suddenly I
hear a voice the S&P is falling where
can I sell 50 million dollars it's a
chaotic environment my heart beats
rapidly as I desperately tried to keep
my cool
finally the clock strikes 5:00 p.m. and
I breathe a sigh of relief as I manage
to leave the trading floor in one piece
as I sit in traffic on my way home I
feel anxious and struggle to focus as my
mind wanders off and after Synder for a
couple of minutes I noticed a
well-dressed middle-aged man trying to
cross a one-way road with no traffic
lights in sight and I think to myself
how strange what's he doing in the
middle of the road I observe as he makes
his way and as I get closer I knew that
he has a cane I notice is actually blind
so I merely jump out of my car offer my
assistance and ask him whether he needs
a ride anyway and to my surprise without
any hesitation he smiles at me
introduces himself as Eustace and gives
me his destination it wasn't a very long
ride but one through the interesting
conversation I asked the man
how do you manage to keep your composure
when in such a tense environment and
then he proceeded to tell me a story
about how he had not always been blind
and how losing his sight led him to pay
more attention to his surroundings he
told me they'd been a long journey for
him letting go of the resentment that he
had towards the world and towards the
circumstances that left him losing his
sight and through that process he
learned how to remain calm especially
when he felt lost or insecure I had to
learn not to focus on what was happening
now how else would I find my way that's
what he told me in that moment in that
very moment I came to a sudden
realization let go focus and listen you
see like that man I was stuck in my past
I let my anxiety take control of me as I
imagined worst case now for my future
based off previous economic downturns do
you ever feel as though you're the
person the middle the road with dozens
of cars honking at you
I suddenly do life's events often
approaches in a form of fast moving cars
in a busy road leaving us feeling lost
and insecure and these feelings are
amplified as ruminate on our past or on
uncertainties in our future how are we
able to navigate through the noise that
life presents unless we're better able
to manage our thoughts and focus on what
matters most to us as I gave more
thought to men's words I reflected upon
a concept called mindfulness mindfulness
is by no means a new topic in fact it's
been around for many many years it's
letting go of all thoughts in the past
and future and bringing increased
awareness to the present moment in our
everyday lives it's been shown to have a
number of benefits and is practiced by
some of the largest companies in the
world General Mills instituted a seven
week mindfulness program for its
employees the program aims to get its
leaders to develop their minds capacity
to pay attention both to themselves and
to others
was usually successful in fact 80% of
senior executives have reported improved
decision-making skills after taking the
class google has a now famous
mindfulness course called
search within yourself it's a rock-solid
business friendly mindfulness program
composed of practical ways to develop
three traits train your attention
develop self-awareness and create useful
mental habits the program was
oversubscribed it has a minimum waiting
time of no fewer than six months but how
does mindfulness make us better leaders
well there are many ways but what
Eustace learned that day was how to not
let his negative thoughts from his past
affect his present moment or his
perceptions of the future
better managing our thoughts extends to
a business context through a phenomenon
called sunk caused bias this is a bias
that a cousin one is invested so much
into a hopeless project that they cannot
bring themselves to stop for the fear of
losing all that was invested san'ko's
buys leads to future irrational business
decisions let's think about that for a
second imagine you enter an ice cream
shop and purchase an expensive yet
elaborate double chocolate peanut butter
ice cream half way through eating it you
start to feel sick do you throw the
remainder away or do you feel obliged to
finish it only because you spend so much
money on it already devouring that
remaining bit of ice cream won't bring
your money back in fact you might have
more to lose in the form of lost
pleasures or increased glucose levels
Suncoast buys the thinking trap and
practicing mindfulness reduces the
tendency to allow prior unrecoverable
costs to affect future decisions the
consequences of not better managing our
thoughts extends beyond the individual
or corporate level to a country level I
grew up in an apartheid trouble South
Africa where segregation was rife The
effect of this environment were damaging
to the emotional state of the population
where the consequence is still prevalent
today 21 years after democracy South
Africa's population is worried that its
future will end up like its past
leading to a mindset that promotes
social divide and impacts economic
performance ever since
reduce this to me be more mindful has
meant being able to let go focus and
listen it's the ability to let go of my
regrets in the past or my anxiety in the
future and to take a moment to focus and
listen truly listen to myself and to
others think about the last time you're
in conversation with someone that you
struggle to focus or listen to on what
to what they're saying maybe you are
thinking about what's in response
judging what they were saying or maybe
you're daydreaming altogether sometimes
or even too busy to listen down in a
thought needs or beliefs when was the
last time you listened to yourself fast
for a couple of months I'm back in the
trading floor but this time with a
different mindset let go focus and
listen I let go of the anxiety that I
had towards the uncontrollable events in
my life one tool that I found useful
well there are started reframing certain
situations as opportunities to grow
rather than as chances to fail so
instead of thinking a poor performance
today could lead to me losing my job I
thought I have a fantastic opportunity
to help my clients through difficult
economic times I found there was a lot
more energized to the task at hand and I
was actually better at my job I started
to focus more on the positives in my
life
including those little things that we
sometimes take for granted so for
example when driving home from work I
thought of a few things that I was
grateful for as opposed to replaying the
frustrating moments that I experienced
throughout the day this increased my
levels of happiness and made me a better
colleague and finally I listened to
myself as I reflected I realized that
throughout my life I'd been to results
focused especially on the trading floor
and I never really took the time to
fully appreciate what I learned
throughout the journey I started putting
mini pauses between my actions which
cleared my mind and allowed me to focus
more on what I was doing in that moment
I will likely never meet Eustace again
but I'll never forget the lesson that I
learned that day life really resembles
work on a clear or straight path but
rather looks like being blindfolded on a
busy road that's scary
so the next time you find yourself in
the middle of the road
we doesn't have cars honking at you
remember let go focus and listen listen
to those around you and listen to your
heart thank you